you might have the stomach for a fight
rookie but I'm here to teach you about
the skills and the tools and the
resistance uses to even the odds against
the kDa you're a rookie now it turns out
to show some aptitude and we can talk
about upgrading
the Korean People's Army have our city
under lockdown
they've got drones air support vehicles
and their high-tech guns our user locked
with biometrics so we'd have to cook up
our own homebrew arsenal here in my
armor you'll find some real American
ingenuity of work I created a modular
weapon system meaning you can change up
your firearms in the field
this way our reliable friend the shotgun
to become fully automatic or even an
inferno launcher if you need a little
more bang for your buck
now every best weapon is multiple combat
configurations but it doesn't stop there
you can swap out on Universal
attachments on the fly and customize any
one of three hard points you need to
swipe some NORC no problem add a muzzle
break and scope a resistance fight our
death to the situation that's how we
survive but guns will only get you so
far the guerrilla toolkit is your best
friend rookie we've developed four
devices that you'll need to master
unless you want to die agree more
the centuries are great against
personnel and an IEE D gives you an
explosive solution to heavier armor if
you're in the mood for something a
little more versatile we've got the hack
tool it'll fry security cameras and turn
drones and automated turrets against the
kPa
and if you need to have flank the enemy
the destruction tool could buy some time
he tied them in the tool kit can be
deployed in multiple ways throw it and
trigger it or lay a trap but my personal
favorite is the RC car
nothing beats a mobile AED you can craft
in the field so be sure to scavenge for
resources all those tricks are wasted if
you don't know how to use them that's
why we trained in gorilla warfare learn
to ambush patrols mark your targets and
spring the perfect surprise attack then
get the hell out before the
reinforcements arrive if you need help
recruit other freedom fighters to fight
alongside
kappa mobility but sometimes you need
pure speed the bike lets you navigate
this open world fast
if you want to get sneaky wait until
nightfall and attack your targets equip
your weapons with silencers we'll take
them down close and personal they would
do the same to you in an instant you
have to know when to fight when to run
and when to hide but if we don't win the
hearts and minds of the people we've got
no hope